[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas mal d des deux manchester ici qui
sont des travailleurs sans papiers et à
partir du moment que cette pandémie et
juni et ceux restés à côté ils sont pas
payés ni quand ils sont dans le foyer
tout ils n'ont pas de ressources toutes
les personnes qui sort là on est là à
cause des paquets on n'est pas là pour
tirer quelqu'un on n'est pas un voleur
on n'est pas pour gaspé quelque chose
aux gens se marrent papiers pour
travailler
toi même tu sais on a travaillé beaucoup
on apprend à déposer un talus espagne
beaucoup payent pour l'honneur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
[Musique]
temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]